et thanks Trisha
so I guess I'll tell you today about a
new candidate for office station and
this is sort of a pretty significant
departure from the existing schemes we
have and so if you haven't if you zoned
out out of the recent works on i/o you
should still be able to to understand
this the stock and and then the ideas
are fairly simple so I'll be able to
explain the construction in detail which
is actually pretty simple which is a an
added benefit of this this scheme so let
me get started and also you know the
scheme is simple and so if you have any
questions please PLEASE interrupt and
ask question and I'm happy to elaborate
and explain further and this work is is
joint with which we Connie Cohen and
Julia so let's get started so
okay so I'll start with some basic
information you know basic stuff about
obfuscation you probably know it but
just for the sake of everybody who you
know so that everybody is on the same
page so the goal of office casein is to
make computer programs unintelligible
without affecting their functionality so
in particular if let's say we have a
party Alice and she holds a program P in
our mine and it could be in her favorite
programming language she would like to
office cape this program and give the
office skated words into Bob such that
Bob can execute now this office cater
version on his computer just as he could
have executed the original program P but
that was somehow wants to hide the
secrets that were embedded inside the P
from Bob in particular since Bob will
have access to the sophisticated a
program so defining office keishon is is
not a you know it's not immediate and in
fact it was some it took some effort to
define off the station and here's sort
of the most natural notion of security
in definition for ossification so we
have we considered a randomized
procedure oh that takes as input a
program C or a circuit C and outputs the
office catered circuit or C and the
functionality requirement is that the
obfuscated circuit C should compute the
same function as C right if you want the
office catered words and to preserve the
functionality then there's the
efficiency requirement that the office
catered circuit should not be much
larger than the circuitry so which is
more formally stated as office catered C
of a skater of C is at most
polynomially larger than C and the third
requirement which is the
unintelligibility requirement or the
security requirement here we have
multiple motion and sort of the most
natural motion is what barack had all
called the virtual black box notion what
this notion says is that for every
diverse 3a there exists the simulator
such that for every circuit see the
office catered version of the circuit if
versus given office catered words in a
circuit that's equivalent to giving the
simulator Oracle access to the circuit
and the size of the circuit in other
words if I give the adverse with your
office catered circuit it doesn't learn
anything more than what it could have
learned using just Oracle access to the
circuit see okay so the sort of a very
natural notion a but unfortunately in
the same word Barak at all sure that
this notion is actually in for
impossible to realize in particular they
sure that there are circuits for which
this notion is actually impossible okay
so they also introduced this slightly
weaker notion of what they called
indistinguishability authorization which
has had tremendous impact in the recent
period so in particular this notion is
[ __ ] so if you have two circuits c1
and c2 which compute the same function
and are of the same size then the
obfuscation or one of them is
indistinguishable from the obfuscation
of one in particular if I office gate
one of these two circuits and give the
obfuscation to you you cannot guess
which circuit was obfuscated and this is
true even if you have knowledge of both
the circuits even see okay so a point
here to notice that inefficient IO is
always possible so in particular the
obfuscation algorithm could just take a
list all possible circuits the computer
since we're looking at circuits that
compute a particular function could look
at all circuits that compute the same
function and output lexicographically
the first function in that list where
the list is you know the lexicographic
ordering is is based on some fixed form
and and this will give you an
indistinguishable your office cater but
the challenge here is that this is going
to be efficient and it's sort of the
main goal of cryptography
indistinguishability office station is
to make this disk anon achill ization
efficient so the you know at first sight
that this notion of indistinguishable
the obfuscation might seem rather weak
but sort of perhaps the
the strongest the philosophical
justification for why this is a good
notion was provided by Bill Bassett and
rod Blum and the idea is that if I take
a circuit see and and you know these are
the same sir could have written the same
circuit twice if I look at the best
possible obfuscation of this circuit and
and then I look at the the same circuit
padded with a bunch of no operation
gates and was to use an
indistinguishability office cater to
offer escape the to then I cannot
distinguish whether our office gated the
best possible obfuscation or just the
original circuit padded with a bunch of
normal operation gates so we can
therefore sort of this suggests that the
industry the office keishon obtained by
indistinguishability office gating a
padded circuit is as good as the best
possible off decision and this sort of a
intuition is what provides the strength
for industry ability obfuscation that is
you know in whatever application we
might be able to wear we might be
interested in using obfuscation
indistinguishability obfuscation
already offers whatever is the best
achievable okay and this is the reason
for a significant number of applications
and I won't go into the applications
just and you know probably you've seen
some of them at least in a functional
encryption deniable encryption to Ron
and PC and so on so now for the focus of
this talk I wanted to focus on just
constructing authorization which relies
all these application and and this is
where there is a lot of work been since
2013 were we saw some of the the first
construction for indistinguishability
office keishon based on multi linear map
so they've been various lying the work
that have emerged but even the the line
of work from multilinear maps there's
been sort of immense amount of work and
you know this picture shows you some
some of these works that used
multilinear maps to get off the station
in all kinds of different ways and and
there are a bunch of construction some
in the standard model some assuming
specialized the
a modeling of the multimedia Maps there
were however there were attacks both on
the multilinear maps and and I'll talk a
little more about it
as well as the office keishon
construction based on multimedia maps
but the bottom line is in this space we
have some candidate constructions which
are currently known to resist the known
attacks on multi new maps I've stated
here one as an example based on the ggs
13 loci maps but they're also candidates
based on CLP 13 or CLT 15 and ggh 15
opening maps the second line of work
that has emerged is it's constructing
authorization using these low complexity
PR G's and additionally standard
assumptions in particular the one on by
linear maps and so on so this is sort of
the second line of work it emerged
bye-bye you know the efforts were
started with the realizing office
keishon constructions using little
making little use of multi linear maps
in particular when you know originally
office keishon construction required
multi linear maps with large multi
leonid linearity and there was effort to
reduce the level of multi linearity
ultimately we ended up at obfuscation
candidates based on just by linear maps
and these low complexity PR keys and
there are other parts for example the
gentry at all construction gentry dodge
a plow and cane which uses tensor
product based constructions and then
there are also attempts at constructing
trilinear maps for example by twan okay
so they're sort of there are other paths
as well but the first two that I
mentioned the multi dia maps and these
low complexity pure G's are the most
popular ones and and sort of something
common in all these parts you know the
popular and the other sort of pots for
office keishon has been that all of them
have gone via sort of starting with new
or newish computational problems so for
example the original multi Nia Maps
started with these new assumptions and
multi linear maps they were rooted in n
true assumption but they may assume
something stronger analogously the the
law of the special PRG constructions
they are also assuming some things you
know special properties of these newly
constructed pseudo-random generators
however once we make those assumptions
these new assumptions the constructions
themselves are are pruned based on these
hard problems okay so I say argued
because these assumptions themselves can
be a little you know they're new and
they're not as well understood so I've
upset may be argued but the the
reductions are you know we can get
proofs for them and another sort of the
problem with this these approaches sir
for all of them um while currently you
know in each of these categories we have
candidates which are known to resist you
know our current understanding of the
the crypt analysis however they've sort
of all gone gone through this break and
repair cycle so for example we saw a tax
on multi linear map candidate by Quran
at all and who Jia
there were also attacks by for example
by MSC a and and further on the
obfuscation candidates based on multi
linear Maps there were originally these
sum of squared attacks on the low
complexity pure G's world which were
used for constructing authorization so
and the similar is also true about the
other parts for example the the the try
linear map candidate we saw a break and
repair so I call that as well so for all
these methodologies while we currently
have candidates where you know there is
just known attacks but they have all
gone through this break and repair cycle
and while we are concurrently learning
there's sort of this may be a sense that
you have to start with some new
assumptions and build on top of them
utilize office keishon okay so you have
to start with new assumptions and maybe
our understanding is limited right now
and as we go further we break them and
we repair them and so on will ultimately
get appreciation schemes that that we
can whose security we can rely on
okay so this is sort of the approach
that has currently been taken we make
new assumptions and we hope that we can
get candidate constructions which will
be secure
okay and the hope is ultimately you know
maybe we start with the assumption that
maybe we can the weaken the assumptions
and get things from from l.w however
this has not happened so far but that's
sort of the the goal okay and then maybe
this is essential and part of the reason
there is that we have some negative
results in particular there's an
impossibility result saying that you
cannot get indistinguishability office
kitchen for all circuits based on let's
say if you are access to evasive office
you know obfuscation for evasive
circuits so for example if you could all
the lockable we already have lockable
authorisation from from lattices
there is evidence that that is not going
to be enough to do obfuscation for all
circuit at least in a even you know in a
black box way but even in sort of some
non black box way so maybe this provides
some evidence or some justification for
why news on students need it and maybe
this is the way to go but they're sort
of an alternate methodology that's often
used in in crypto so there's this one
methodology we try to base things on
concrete assumptions and so on and then
maybe we get started with assumptions
which are sort of new but hopefully you
know as as we pin them down to something
simpler and simpler even if it's not
something that's you know completely
standard right now maybe over the years
we'll have built some confidence on them
but then there's this alternate
methodology in crypto which is sort of
also proved to be immensely influential
and useful though it has its own caveat
and it sort of gives it there too
such examples of this methodology which
is sort of random Oracle model and the
other being circular security and you
know they're clearly differences between
that we do of these but I'm sort of
putting these two sort of ways of
constructing crypto primitives together
because there's a heuristic aspect to
both of them
okay so both the random Oracle model and
the way we can think of just take any
encryption scheme and assume it's
circularly secure and they're sort of
both very heuristic in nature where we
don't give any proofs but there's a
distinction in how this methodology goes
with respect to the first methodology or
basing things in concrete assumption
when we talk about a specific assumption
for example you know let lwe you know
we're sort of saying look this is secure
but when we're talking about circle of
security we really don't have a finger
that are first of all we're talking
about a heuristic that goes for not just
one encryption scheme but many
encryption schemes right so you can
assume any encryption scheme it's of
collaboration here and sometimes that
conjecture might be true or sometimes
might be false and similarly for the
random Oracle model you if you assume
that a hash function can be modeled as a
random Oracle you're assuming something
about not just one hash function
potentially many many hash functions and
also you're you're not putting
completely your finger on what the
assumption is so so that this is a very
holistic in nature so there are
shortcomings of both of them we know
constructions where the random Oracle
methodology is has pitfalls and
similarly for circular security we know
encryption schemes which are not a
circularly secure so in particular when
I give you an encryption of the secret
key we know that those encryption
schemes are insecure so we have you know
there is a room for for error in this
method all however we're still you know
the both these techniques have been very
useful in particular for example random
Oracle provides us with some of the most
efficient signature schemes in
particular in terms of the signature
sizes
unless you deserve to ya do special
assumptions for example
indistinguishable the obfuscation gives
you a short signature scheme its
signature scheme the chart signatures
but if we wanted to get something
efficient then you know the sort of a
very successful
methodology similarly circular security
has been crucial to the designer fully
homomorphic encryption scheme so for
example right now we don't know we only
know leveled homomorphic encryption
scheme from from lattices and we have to
assume circle security in order to get
fully homomorphic encryption which we
which has had tremendous impact in in
cryptography so these techniques while
heuristic I have had significant impact
and I wanted to spend some time on
bringing this this you know comparison
because the construction that I'm going
to present is going to live within this
framework so we're going to use a
heuristic switch sort of combined
circular security and the random Oracle
model in in ways which we don't clearly
understand and get an efficient
construction but at the same time we
won't know how to break it so that's a
so I see there was a question let's see
yes it does and so the question is does
the basic function imply something less
powerful than witness like witness
encryption yes it does
however a we know that even witness
encryption is not enough as a black box
or even to some extent some non black
box to utilize obfuscation for all
circuits hopefully that answers the
question if it means if your follow up
questions feel free to type in the
window or unmute yourself and no okay so
let me move on so in the the the crux so
this slide is that you know we're going
to get an obfuscation construction where
we're not going to make any new
assumptions we're gonna make assumption
that we understand but use them in ways
that we know just as we do for the
random Oracle methodologies repository
okay so the advantages of this alternate
approach and that we're not going to
have to start with the new assumptions
we're not going to have to start with
multilinear maps or special PR T's or
trilinear maps or anything you will
start with things that we can all agree
our you know with confidence in their
security and and and then we'll use them
in sort of ways we don't understand the
second advantage is that the the the get
a construction which is not going to be
a one candidate we're gonna get a family
your family so we're going to say if you
have a generic primitive X then you know
you can and you use it in some way you
get a office case so maybe you could
find and we have many natural provably
secure instantiation effects of course
you know the the constructions is
heuristic and then so that needs further
strain okay so in a nutshell the result
that we have is that we're going to
start with certain hormone morphic
encryption schemes these homomorphic
encryption schemes are the ones that
we're going to use are going to be based
on standard assumption so we're going to
have a scheme tutor which are already
considered in the literature and and
we're going to start with these schemes
and combine them heuristically and
angola
will get office casey okay so
that's the the high-level result to
expand this picture this is going to be
done in two steps so what we're going to
do is we're going to take fully
homomorphic encryption so I said I
started with homomorphic encryption
scheme so I'm going to use throw three
homomorphic encryption or the
homomorphic encryption scheme good setup
of the thief three different flavors the
first flavor is homomorphic encryption
with linear decryption or a fully
homomorphic encryption with linear
decryption and this is something that we
know how to construct virtually all fhe
schemes that we know satisfy this
property we're also going to start with
a linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
with split encryption I haven't defined
what split decryption is but I'll get to
that in a second so that's the second
flavor of homomorphic encryption scheme
that we'll use and will also use
candidate hash functions you could use
AES or anything that you like but you
can also construct them from a linearly
homomorphic encryption scheme okay so
all these primitives can be constructed
from
homomorphic encryption schemes with
certain additional properties and I'll
talk more about them in a minute I'm
going to combine them in some way to get
something that we called split fhe okay
so note that I didn't define what split
decryption was in here encryption I'm
going to do that it's going to be the
same property for split fhe and I've not
yet yet define it I will define it in
the next slide once we get this
heuristic part out of the way we can
then say that once your split fhe then
that probably implies indistinguishable
okay so the heuristic part of the
construction is limited to the one the
horizontal arrow in this picture going
from the homomorphic encryption schemes
to split apache that's the heuristic
part that's what I'll spend most time on
and then you know that's what needs more
investigation so sorry Sandra did you
define what split fhe is no I haven't
and then it's on the next slide but but
it's the same property as linear
homomorphism it's both
decryption but I'll define it in a
second okay okay so now let me answer
sharpey's question what is
so we all know what effigy is it
consists of four algorithms Keegan ank
eval and Dec ink and you know the
property that fhe has is you can use the
eval algorithm which takes a ciphertext
is input and a circuit C and outputs an
encryption of the circuit impute
computed on the encrypted message so if
I start with a ciphertext encrypting the
message m then I get back a ciphertext
encrypting C of M splitter fitchy
does as the name suggests split the
decryption algorithm okay so what
splitter 50 does is instead of having
one decryption algorithm we're going to
split it in two parts the hint and rec
so I see some questions I'll answer them
once I finish the swipe the hint
algorithm what it does is it generates
so it takes a ciphertext and a secret
key and generates I think ok so you know
typically decryption takes the
ciphertext and just recovers the
encrypted message and now we're
splitting into two processes parts where
the first part generates a hint and sort
of think of the hint as a helper
information to generate the decryption
right the second is the the public
reconstruction so given the ciphertext
and the hint you can recover the message
am so you don't no longer need the
secret key to decrypt the ciphertext but
only a the hint and you can think of it
as the ciphertext dependent it sort of
secret key that's allowing you to be
here I mean at this point you might
wonder well what's the purpose of the
hint the hint could be the message
itself right so this is where this
non-trivial a--they non-trivial
efficiency requirement comes in is that
we want the hint to be much smaller than
the size of the message okay so I have a
large ciphertext I want to help I have
the large ciphertext you have a large
ciphertext I want decrypt it and give it
P so there is one way I can decrypt it
and give you the message that that's one
way of doing it but I want to reduce the
communication cost in and so what I do
is instead I
decrypted locally but when I do the
decryption I get something small which
is a hint and I give you the hint and
you can now use just a hint to recover
the message is this clear if there any
questions about the split property I can
answer I can also look at the chat and
see if there are questions
so why can't the hint be the secret
pizzas good so the hint can be the
secret key but I'll have a security
requirement that you know if I just use
the the hint as the security secret II
then you can use the same the secret key
to decrypt other ciphertext as well I
haven't yet described the security
property and I'll do that which will
prevent that from happening so what
after you supply the hint why can't we
think of it as if that's directly to M
goes to it yeah because then because I'm
requiring the the hint to be much
smaller than the message okay okay good
so great so there are two triviality
requirements one is the efficiency want
which Shafi asks and the other is the
security requirement which actually
asked and I'm going to explain the
security requirement on the next slide
okay so let me answer this the the
security requirement I think the
questions are with respect to split fhe
so maybe this will answer so you know
the security requirement is is as
natural as it as you might expect so
given the hint you should be able to be
cut with the psychotic but you shouldn't
be able to use it to decrypt other side
right so very definitely what it says is
or you know if you have two messages m0
m1 and a circuit C such that C of M 0 is
equal to C of m1
um then the you know and i and i so i
generate the hint using either CM 0 or
CM 1 you shouldn't be able to general
tell whether you're dealing with CM the
the ciphertext encrypting m0 or a
ciphertext encrypting m1 so this should
be in c 0 at 0 and C 1 H 1 so I'm also
giving the ciphertext to the in perjury
sorry about that
so the adversity is given a encryption
of m0 and a an in hint H 0 or the
adversity is given the ciphertext C 1 or
the hint H 1 and it cannot tell which of
the values it's good doesn't make sense
let me now see what he does doesn't
imply a privacy as well I mean no
because you know the circuit is the same
in both cases
or yeah yeah sure so let me see what the
question is
so by heuristic do you mean if you break
split fhe one does not necessarily one
does not necessarily break a
construction on the left side yes that's
true that's how I interpreted thanked
and the definition of split seems
unrelated to eval so it can be defined
for any PK yes that's also true you can
define it for any PK and that's why you
know we're going to define it also for
linearly homomorphic encryption would
split so is the definition of split
effect see clear there
it's a fhe scheme where I split the
decryption process into two parts that's
the hint generation and the
reconstruction the hint generation
generates a hint that allows you to
decrypt the ciphertext but the
efficiency requirement is that the hint
needs to be small and the security
requirement very roughly is you don't
learn anything more than the ability to
decrypt outside so the hints may be the
same even well it won't be the same but
they won't be the same it's the reason
why they need dick they couldn't be the
same um I guess because well you could
have encryption schemes where that is
that where it might end up happening but
if you think about a natural encryption
scheme encryption of m0 and m1 would
have sort of live in distinct spaces so
but the hint is only two to four
decrypting the result of the circuit yes
yes so it is possible that they might
end up to be the same space but it seems
somewhat like okay unlikely um regarding
the howtechs question you know that you
can define the split property even
without fully homomorphic encryption but
it looks like this security property for
split at the hg sort of inherently
requires some kind of homomorphism
so the way I defined it yes but you
could define it alternatively
without
you know if you didn't have homomorphism
you could define it as saying look if I
give you the hint with respect to a
particular ciphertext you shouldn't be
able to learn anything else about other
independently generated psychotics in
the case of fhe because we're giving a
hint about one ciphertext and where
there are other ciphertext where there's
a computation so maybe the property has
to involve yes did I answer your
question please
yeah I don't I don't know if I
understand it let's say the M doesn't
support any homomorphism at all so
definitely ok ok yes ok yeah ok so let
me so I can also define a stronger
version of split fhe which is something
we will need for office Station where
instead of just giving one hint where
security holds even if I give you a
larger number many hints starting with
the same cycle so very natural
generalization so this is something that
we actually need but you know through
the rest of the talk we'll sort of work
with the weaker property and gloss over
the reason why you need the stronger
property ok so what we have defined so
far is what split fhe is now let me tell
you what the three ingredients that I'm
using are ok so the first ingredient I'm
using is fully homomorphic encryption
with linear decryption this is something
that we all know is just basically an
FFT scheme with nearly linear decryption
wherein we say that the decryption
algorithm is given a ciphertext is
linear and the secret so in particular I
can take the the ciphertext in in its
natural form or reexpress such that the
inner product of the secret key you know
again expressed in some suitable form
with the ciphertext yields the message
with some small error E ok so in where
the message is encoded but some kind of
an error correcting code for typical
fully homomorphic encryption
scheme that could just be encoding it
and for example the higher order bits of
the output space and then this is what
you get so this is basically you know
this this linear or here me here
decryption property holds words to be
for all known fhe schemes so you know we
can take any of those schemes and plug
it into into our current construction
and we'll get a candidate for office
case okay so this is the the first thing
there any question I see there are some
questions
yeah okay I think I was just answering
some questions get back to this line so
sunjin just to clarify the decryption
this thing you don't have any bounds on
the complexity of the decryption this
thing is the size of the hint should be
small yeah just the stage 1 and stage 2
decryption algorithms they need not be
yeah ok so I already defined the split
property for fhe I can similarly define
the split property for a linearly
homomorphic encryption scheme and and to
give you a you know just to give you an
example of such a linearly homomorphic
encryption scheme with split be
captioned something that was already
studied in the literature is the the
Daimler direct encryption scheme so Dan
what you reckon corruption scheme
consists of the public parameter n which
is the product of two large frontal RSA
modulus a public key which is N and Zeta
a a large constant say greater than 1
and encryption algorithm corresponds to
encrypting a message M corresponds to
taking a randomness are in Zn and a
message m in Zn to viateur so the
message space is much larger than the
randomness space that's used to generate
the cipher text in the encryption is
generated by computing this equation
which is R to the N to the Zeta times 1
plus N to the M mod n Zeta plus 1 okay
so that's the encryption algorithm for
damge Tirek and it's easy to observe
that it has linearly homomorphic
property so if you take two psychotics
and you multiply them you see that the
randomness is get multiplied and
gathered together and the second part of
the the ciphertext consists of 1 plus n
to the power m and the mess you know
this part also gets multiplied and you
get M 1 plus M 2 in the D exponent so
you get an encryption of the some of the
messages under a new randomness so it
has the linear homomorphic property
that's decide but what's nice is that
this encryption scheme also comes with
in particular I can break the decryption
algorithm into two parts the first
generates the hint in particular for any
ciphertext if I disclose the randomness
are then you can use that to to learn
what the message M is because you can
remove the are to the end to the Zeta
part and then recover the message m from
from whatever is left over and so this
is exactly what my hint is going to be
so given a ciphertext I can compute C to
the N to the minus theta and you know if
you do the computation it corresponds
just to Ardmore then and once our mod n
is provided anybody can use it to
decrypt the ciphertext without any
knowledge of the security and it should
sort of roughly have the the security
property that was desired because you
know I'm effectively leaking the
randomness that was used to generate one
ciphertext I'm not leaking anything
about the secret key so nothing should
be a the with regard to the efficiency
property
observe that the be the value Rho is
comes from Zn which is much smaller than
the message space which comes from Zn to
the Z n to the power theta where Zeta is
you know if it's large enough it's going
to be much larger than Zn so my message
is going to be much larger than the
randomness and so I get both the desired
security and efficiency so that's why
you don't use like a year or something
yes I have a question for you so is this
why they introduced this system because
this is because well they didn't talk I
think they didn't care about the the
split decryption what they cared about
was the efficiency that you get the
homomorphic encryption where the with
rate one in particular the size of the
ciphertext is roughly the same as the
size of the message and additionally you
can perform linear homomorphism
okay thanks where is this bum what is
this room
I don't remember the year maybe I don't
know maybe someone in the before my time
so I don't remember the arrangement is
around 2004 or so yeah so linear
homomorphism was a value for some
application okay yeah also the
efficiency because you get shorter cycle
things so this is awesome
yeah the security property for first
split this is something you can actually
prove it's not a heuristic assumption
about it yeah great okay so now that we
have you know linear homomorphic flip
Eclipse and we all know and you know you
can also get a construction from from
from lwe if you wanted a but you know
that sort of a construction that we have
in the paper I wanted to give examples
of these things which existed in the
literature prior to our work
ok so then we also have cryptographic
hash functions you know we know how to
construct hash function you can also use
homomorphic encryption schemes to
construct it and as a heads up we're
going to model the hash function as a
random Oracle in our construction ok so
now that the you know all the the you
know the definitions in this picture are
complete let me give you the that step
from growing from split the step in
going from split fhe to
indistinguishable reallocation that's
sort of the the easy step and then we'll
see the heuristic step and I'll just do
it in one slide and give you the high
level idea for it and then you can look
at the paper for each so Senjem just to
make sure from this previous slide so
you're saying that all these three block
boxes you can get under lwe yes ok so
that that part there's nothing you
ristic at this point
well there is circular security that is
he respect you're gonna have to use you
ok that part is hipster and you do need
to fully yes we need we're gonna use
circular security and even more involved
way so the heuristic also is going to
push in its own forms of circular
security but we'll see that in a second
but so
for what I've said the only holistic
part is fully homomorphic encryption
yeah okay um the the step from going
from split fhe to io is actually fairly
easy I mean I'm there there's some
details I'm gonna skip here since it's
an approvable but just to give you an
idea how it works is that what I can do
is I can use split fhe to compress a
truth table for a function f how could I
do that well I could give you any so
they'd be the compressed version of the
truth table is going to consist of an
encryption of the function description
or the circuit description per app and a
hint edge for decrypting the following
ciphertext which is written in red on
the site it consists of encryption of PK
of f1 all the way to f2 to the lambda
where lambda is the input one okay so
this is the I give it as the backing for
this and observe that the hint is going
to be much smaller than the ciphertext
and if the decryption of the circuit F
is small I'm essentially compressing the
tooth table of the function f into
something much smaller and and given the
hint you can recover the entire truth
table given you know the ciphertext the
encryption of F and the hint you can
recover you can first compute the entire
encrypted block table and then use the
hint decrepit and recover the and as
shown by Lin at all this is something
that's enough to construct IO if you
nail w en IO in this primitive what they
call x io in their paper we can get
indistinguishable you're an alternative
way would be to use functional
encryption from GK PVC and and and one
could get I of that way and that would
give you a construction of EFI schemes
and from there you could then
instantiate you could go further by
Patong Skiba comes knockin or
ununpentium and get
application I see some questions
so in the constructions it is totally
independent of the message size is does
it I think it just needs to be smaller
but I'll have to double-check but in the
construction it is it's just much
smaller I think it's just much smaller
okay so let me move on to the more
interesting part which is how does a I'm
sorry
so you said that this isn't quite formal
there's something missing like this
looks convincing to me on this slide so
in the construction you need to this
thing needs to be repeated there many
times and you have to amortize the size
of the public key in split fhe could be
large so you have to amortize that cost
as well so you need that stronger
security that I mentioned personal
identity before but I'm not gonna make
some I hope that makes some sense I
don't want to go too much into it but
it's a sense this makes sense it's just
that the public key could be large and
and to accommodate for the fact you have
to do a little more and that's why you
need the stronger security for a split a
50 that I mentioned of got it Thanks
I'm still be confused the hints of the
pair on the side protects how do we
compute the ciphertext don't you over
the minutes for the original cyber
techno song reacting like that
no no so given a ciphertext this is if
it's a this is an fhe scheme so given an
encryption of F you can compute whatever
you want I see so you're on the
evaluation Algar so I start with a small
ciphertext you run anywhere then and and
produce this gigantic cyber thing I see
that's something everybody can do right
and all I give the hint for this
gigantic ciphertext but since the cipher
the hint is small you can now compute
the gigantic site the text yourself and
decrypt it using this small thing that
ID I see thanks yeah okay great yes it
does it so why do you need to go through
the immediate intermediate step of the
non-trivial I Oh instead of doing IO
directly well I mean
I don't fully understand the question
because oh so from my understanding the
current efficient scheme is the
encryption of the function and the hint
yes hello
why don't I just encrypted a function
which take normal input size and oh good
good good fantastic so I think they'd be
to generate the hint I have to first
generate the entire encryption in sorry
meaning 1 2 f2 to the lambda yes so now
then generating the obfuscation would be
extremely expensive it would take long
time and also will take a long time to
to compute the output it wouldn't be
polynomial in so just another question
so what it give at least a candidate if
you can do the office kitchen
for example the obfuscation time take
exponential time but it ought to put is
polynomial yes you could probably all
work here so the size is not a problem
size is not the problem it's just your
computation time yes ok thank you
great question so now we have you know
seen all the the well understood and the
provable parts let me get to the
heuristic which is sort of a you know
the the interesting part okay so the
first attempt is is going to be as
follows so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to publish these public parameters
that are going to consist off the public
key of an fhe scheme the public key of
the linearly homomorphic scheme and I'm
going to give an encryption of the
secret key of an apache scheme under the
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
ok so these are the three parameters
that I publish and yeah so now let's say
that I'm trying to construct a splitter
fhe let's say I have encryption
a lot you know a large or a long length
message em under the fhe scheme I would
like to give a hint enabling the
bickerson so here is a quick idea you
know I have two encryption schemes which
have sort of very properties one is a
fully homomorphic and the other is a
linear homomorphic with split decryption
what if I put them two together can I
immediately get sort of a split at the
cheese scheme well to some extent yes
right so I can immediately take a
ciphertext under the fhe scheme do a key
switch get an encryption of the message
under the linearly homo more linearly
homomorphic encryption scheme and then
once I have deciphered texts and
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme I
could give a hint just for the linearly
homomorphic encryption scheme that would
allow you to decode error correcting
code error correcting encoding of the
message M plus the error once you
recover that you can recover the message
on that okay so let me then let me
repeat and you know if the questions I
can can answer so what I'm doing is I
have two encryption schemes one is fully
homomorphic the other is linearly
homomorphic but additionally comes with
split a correction so I'm going to put
the two together to get a fully
homomorphic encryption would split the
fhe and how I'm going to do that is that
anytime I need to give a hint I will
first do a key switch to the the
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
and give a hint for the linear
homomorphic encryption scheme but
because it was already had the split
property right and I can do this ski
switch from the for Homo effector -
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
because the decryption algorithm of the
fully homomorphic encryption scheme is
lean so that's the is that clear
questions on this good do this LHC dot
encryption
have pika door of lhe or not sorry this
is a type of this would be PK of energy
any more questions so let me see I think
there were some questions in the chat
window they got a lot of fights okay
okay so you might ask well does it is it
already enough well the problem is that
if I give this hint it it the saint's
allows anybody to learn ECC of M plus e
from which you know in fact we leak some
information about E and potentially also
about the secret key of tfhe scheme
right so in particular if I give
multiple hints it gives you a bunch of
linear equations then the secret key of
the fhe scheme and you could solve those
linear equations to get the escape idea
so this is while it does it get the the
efficiency properly that's desired it
doesn't get the desired security
property in particular if I give
multiple hints I can leak the secret
beauty of that easy well how could I fix
it you know this is a an idea that's
used you know at several places in in
instead of trying to hide the error when
for fhe scheme and the idea is to sort
of use some kind of a noise smudging so
what if I had access to an article and
and you know looking ahead this is where
random Oracle is going to come into play
that gave me an encryption of a mning
under the linearly homomorphic
encryption scheme which is small but
much larger than the error that ends up
in the size of the error e then I could
have just added these two cipher texts
and given a hint for these two you know
the the sum of these two ciphertext
rather than just the original cycle
doesn't make sense if I had access to
this sum some way of sampling these
small you know these linearly
homomorphic encryption ciphertext or
small random values then I would be good
to go and you know I couldn't do this
while a random Oracle I could plug in
the where the random Oracle would be
queried on the ciphertext for which I'm
trying to give
and then I get this decipher fiction and
and and I could do this noise smudging
and give the hint and that would be all
using it you could still recover the the
message I'm because II plus s is not
going to be as large but it's going to
prevent the attack that was highlighted
on the previous life which is that you
could learn the secret key given
multiple K so this is a very natural
idea um the problem is that we do not
have this article in particular the
linear homework encryption scheme does
not have you know it's not possible to
do sample ciphertext which encrypts
small random values okay so that's a
problem
so we do not have this Oracle as a side
note if we did have access to this this
article we can actually get a provably
secure construction for split fhe a in
the random Oracle model and you know you
can an alternative way of thinking of
the result at this point is well this
can be thought of as a completeness
result if you have a mechanism for
sampling encryption of short small
random values then that's enough to
realize obfuscation but since we don't
have it we're going to sort of build a
heuristic around it you to make it
happen so how are we going to do it so
note that we do not have a mechanism to
sample encryptions of small values but
the the dam does it extreme that I
showed you does have the property that
the cipher texts are pseudo random so
you we could sample random sites at X
encrypting random values not just small
random value on so of course you know if
I plug in a small instead of a small
random value just a large and item value
here then I'm in trouble because this is
going to not just flood the error but
also the message and therefore the hint
is going to be used to useless so we
want to somehow use the cipher text that
encrypts a a large random value and
convert it into something that encrypts
a small random out well how could we do
that
well we have fhe to our rescue so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna in
addition to the public parameter so
previously we had just encrypted the
secret key of the fhe scheme under the
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
now I'm also going to give an encryption
of the secret key of the linearly
homomorphic encryption scheme under the
fhe scheme
okay so we know so we're gonna resume
circle of security between the fhe and
the linearly homomorphic encryption so
I'm going to give the secret key of the
fhe scheme under the linear homomorphic
encryption the secret key of the
linearly homomorphic under the effect
okay so this is where I'm adding the
circularity if I have a visual access to
this parameter and I have encrypt access
to a encryption of a large random value
R under the linearly homomorphic
encryption scheme I can do a key switch
and move it to an fhe scheme right so if
I have because I have an encryption of
the linearly whom the secret key of the
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme I
could decrypt the linearly homomorphic
encryption ciphertext under the Apache
now that i have encryption of are under
the fhe i could remove the higher-order
bit because it's an fhe i could compute
arbitrary circuits and also remove the
higher order bits and i get there the
lower order bits are in the opechee now
that i have the lower order bits i can
decrypt do the key switch back to the
linearly homomorphic encryption scheme
and I get an encryption of the lower
order bits plus some noise which results
from the decryption process is this
making sense so what I have achieved is
I had an encryption of something random
under the linearly homomorphic
encryption scheme and what I have ended
up with is an encryption of the lower
order bits of the random value plus some
noise under the linear little more
and how I've done it is by you know I
couldn't compute arbitrary circuits on
our so I first moved it to fhe deadly
arbitrary computation and brought it
back to linearly homomorphic
there's a big chance wouldn't you get an
error corrected version of RLS peace
bliss noise yeah so I'm thinking of you
know it being encoding the higher order
bits plus noise it only effects the
lower order bits the higher orders bits
are already zero there so why couldn't
you just start with the randomness being
in the under the effigy hood because you
know the ciphertext that there are not
efficiently sampling oh I can only
sample the ciphertext corresponding to
the linearly homomorphic encryption a so
you know for the random Oracle if I feed
something it gives me a random string
the random string has to be from the
range of the size okay for the linearly
homomorphic encryption scheme that
property satisfied not for the Apaches
so what's the hint here is this RLS beat
no so this is the encrypted value now
once I get the ciphertext I've
essentially got an encryption of
something small you know so now what I'm
going to do is I'm going to use this
small and add it to the ECC m plus E and
give the hint for that psychotics that's
my cat okay so the hint is for the
ciphertext which is the error correction
of M plus error plus these are LS B's
exactly so now given the sent you could
recover the higher order bits of the
method the message m and we're hoping
here and this is the heuristic part that
you know because we did this sort of
mumbo-jumbo on our and it's highly
nonlinear we don't know what's happening
and this is sort of something inspired
by the bootstrapping in fhe right so
there when you do bootstrapping we don't
know what's happening it's highly
nonlinear that this is this our LS be
the error in our LSB is unrelated to the
secret key and our in enough of a way
that it hides a and the secret key
so just given the hint you can't recover
the secret
so that's sort of the the heuristic part
in the construction and once you have
this this is sort of the entire
construction and this is the split fhe
scheme a we don't know attacks against
it and sort of the intuition for that
arises from the fact that this
computation is highly nonlinear because
there's a you know fhe a bootstrap
things that are happening along the way
and so on and then you know the further
you can make this even more nonlinear by
introducing more effective good
strapping and this is shown to be in
other contexts useful for example to
teach circuit privacy we don't have a
crew for this but that's that's the he
respected logistic lever so this
heuristic part you could actually would
be provable secure in the random Oracle
model under the circularity assumption
you need more so you need something else
no no if I had an Oracle you know the
random Oracle gave encryptions of
something small that will be provably
secure in the random Oracle model but
the the the Oracle only gives encryption
does something random to bring it to
something small I do it this you know I
I first convert it to fhe and then bring
it back to LHC right that part is you
know you know he restrict that's
essentially be heuristic
right that this our LSB you know it's
it's not our daily speech our LSB some
noise where we're relying on the fact
that order the noise in itself does not
you know cancel some of the the lower
order bits of out of this P does make
and yes so that's sort of the heuristic
that you know when I do this there's
going to be noise there that noise
shouldn't somehow be weirdly correlated
with our LSB itself to be such that when
I give a hint the thing leaks a
relationships of the secret so the point
is that our LSP is big enough that it
really hides he it smudges out like it
but there's some additional noise in the
our LSP that's pretty large and that and
we don't know what that is and and it
it's clearly nonlinear it's not linear
we can further make you know weaken the
relationship by doing additional
bootstrap rings along the way and so on
but that you know that we don't know if
we would help or not help and that's
sort of the heuristic part in the
construction okay okay so that's a you
know that's basically deconstruction
once you assume this is played fhe then
the obfuscation construction you get is
provably secure and in throw the the
heuristic part lies in taking a
ciphertext that encrypts something large
- converting something to something
that's small there are some questions
there's just some discussion happening
yeah so sorry if I missed where do you
use the random Oracle so the random
Oracle is used to sample this encryption
of a large random you know the
ciphertext are so you know if you want
to give a hint for encryption for this
value you feed it to the random Oracle
and out comes this random ciphertext
which you do this heuristic step added
to the key switch to value and give the
hint for that so there will be a
different you know randomization factor
for each ciphertext for which of the
hint will being provided
okay so this say it completes the you
know if there are any questions I let me
see oh there are more in the chat
yes so the dynamo record is used because
you know the ciphertext is going to be
much larger so you feed the random
Oracle a small string and then it spits
out potentially a much larger ciphertext
out okay so to summarize a you know
prior construction and obfuscation
relied on new assumptions and while the
assumptions were new and the
constructions were provably secure so
you started with the new assumption gave
a a provably secure construction based
on that in contrast what we're doing
here is we're starting with standard
crypto primitives that were started in
the past new constructions for these in
the literature how do we combine them in
a in a in a heuristic way to get a
construction the we conjecture is secure
so the it's the construction which is
which is heuristic I think that these
are a very different flavor while the
construction in the first side need more
analysis it's rough you know the kind of
attacks we expect you have are you know
completely devastate the scheme in
contrast I think that the new candy that
we have you know it doesn't necessarily
just present one candidate it's sort of
a family of candidates and and you know
if the scheme ends up being broken it
would it would be weird to see a
correlation between fhe schemes and you
know things based you know on DCR so
sort of a these are very different
assumptions and you know it's a
heuristic that combines the two and for
the scheme to be broken it would have to
use some properties that use them both
in a natural way and then also if the
scheme ends up being broken perhaps it
will give us insights into the security
of fhe schemes itself which also rely on
the circular security heuristic so this
is something that needs a further
investigation and you know needs a
little work so to summarize a you know
prior works used new ingredients to the
lies off the station
in this work we use known ingredients
but we have a new recipe fertilizing a
obfuscation so that's all I wanted to
say so this and this comes with inherent
simplicity for the scheme see also you
know finally I would like to remark that
you know while I presented just the IO
scheme the ideas you know where we can
replace the random Oracle with
additional communication it's possible
to get other applications without any
heuristics so it helps improve the you
know some of the applications where we
can get new results without any
heuristics so the techniques are useful
in besides the context of iOS 4 so
that's all I wanted to say let me see
there are some questions oh I see I
think you answered thank you
yeah first of all people can unmute
understeer thanks son and yeah I think
at this point people can just feel free
to unmute themselves and ask questions
have a question of I think it is one
version which is described using the
random Oracle so what's the input of the
random Oracle so the fact that X for
which we're trying to get the hint the
Sun protects we are trying to keep the
hint is the input of the random Oracle
okay here in the vibrance like is that
the only option that you take the
ciphertext well you could give it the
you know the linearly homomorphic
encryption you know the the value after
the quick switch to the random Oracle as
well
could you see that again you know you if
I'm trying to you know if it's on the
slide that you see on the screen if I'm
trying to give the hint for the
ciphertext that encrypts the message em
then I wanna fresh you know randomizing
term for this ciphertext I could give
the random Oracle this ciphertext and
get a hint or I could do the key
switching and then give the hint right I
could in fact use any intermediate step
of the computation as input to the
random Oracle I mean I'm just using the
in the starting point it's got your
things one sort of like the side
question thing yeah so so okay this is
one mechanism of sort of trying to
smudge noise in a sense yes is it
possible again this will be ristic with
these low complexity pure G's yet have
these assumptions like noise smudging
generators or all these these sort of
projects okay let's assume that that is
secure that that is that assumption
holds any use that assumption to just
add the smashing noise in the linearly
homo impressions of text and not doing
this business of doing the random Oracle
adding and just smashing it basically
give out the seed of the pseudo-random
generator as part of the subtext and
then also evaluate that homomorphic Lee
and then that would automatically no no
I think so so I think there are sort of
two questions right so one is can we
replace this heuristic with the
assumptions that are used in that
context and perhaps maybe
simple construction or something like
that a you know that's totally plausible
I don't know how to do that and and and
and maybe the second question you're
asking is is if I just use you know
because we have full effect see at our
disposal we don't have to use these low
depth PR geez I could just give an
encryption of a PRG C then use that and
expand it and use that to decrypt the
problem is that if I do that then you
know ultimately it's just going to be
these linear functions and I would be
worried about things canceling you know
if it just ends up being linear equation
than the secret key that would be
problematic right so you want these
fresh cipher texts that are sample to be
nonlinear in the OS e maybe maybe maybe
the issues that beam noise that you leak
in that case that will leak the the
original seed itself yes but at the same
time one thing to note here is that you
know the appeared so there's one big
distinction between previous I
approaches and this approach is that in
you know prior works you had an office
keishon that the the noise that was
being added and this is true also about
the nmap is when you you know spit out
something there was a noise there and
you know you could try to solve linear
equations and learn something but in
this case what's happening is you know
computing everything can be computed
inside the belly of the beast right
because you have cool fhe and so you can
sort of compute fresh values there and
try to so you don't have to work with
row these low depth pierdes and so on
also one of the questions will be
heuristic
I'm just asking yeah I was just asking
that so you mentioned about this
heuristic of using the random Oracle to
samples have takes obliviously which
such that they have small messages yeah
possibly you can just also do use io
just to instantiate that yeah
so basically but of course if you have
that then would be good and when
presenting is sort of like this
heuristic way of sampling
phifertex with small where the encrypted
message is small and if you could do it
that that gives you i'll and that's
basically the heuristic part because you
know if you instantiate that itself as
Oracle then you can get a solution I was
just wondering that the the random
Oracle and this is the function that's
computing this Celtics that can itself
we imagine like a spirit program but
maybe for a very small class of phone oh
yeah yeah definitely and then I was
thinking yeah yeah that sort of you can
think of it as a completeness thing that
if I'm authorization for this thing then
you can obfuscate all circuits based on
that but that class doesn't seem like it
may be a class of a function straight
that does seem like you're computing
yeah it is not a it's not evasive some
juices but it is sort of simpler than
some other sense yeah okay a question
about a possible attack Avenue maybe you
can tell me this doesn't make sense so
you have the fully homomorphic
encryption of the lhe secret key yeah
and then you're doing you're doing like
kind of a bootstrapping on this secret
key and and then that's that's going to
have some noise in it the noise you know
evolves in some way and then at the end
the hint essentially reveals this kind
of evolved noise or something very close
to it right so if you and I suppose this
will be done many times or something
like that so if you can somehow
reconstruct the original noise or learn
something about the original noise and
the encryption of the lhe secret key
then then maybe you know you can recover
the energy Syracuse yeah that's a no you
could try and yeah definitely yeah
that's it out that seems to be you know
if you could yeah sounds there's some
probably some high depth yeah there's
some high def function being applied to
the novel's original fhe okay yeah and
you can make it even you know higher
depth right by maybe applying
bootstrapping offered every step yeah
right and that that makes it look like
well it seems hard but I you know I
don't have a good justification yeah
okay thanks
okay okay so why do we need to start
with a fully homomorphic encryption
instead of just level at the first
please oh let's see well I mean
ultimately we will get it actually
because I'm giving the secret key of one
under the other end the other aren't so
right so I'm giving the secret key of
the fxe under the LHC so if that's the
case then I can use these two together
secretly of the fhe under the energy so
but the if the question is why do you
know can we get rid of the fhe by I
guess who I already would know their
depth of the circuit so I could set the
parameter such that I could start with
yeah but you know ultimately you would
get that [ __ ] because you're giving so
yeah people have any more questions yeah
now is the time from don't um you
mentioned you could use out of you paste
lhe you also get the dense ciphertext
property like this would you be able to
use it for the whole thing or yeah so
that you know that that would be needed
for the construction but okay so okay so
you said that this DG construction that
is already as the property of it's
linearly homomorphic I mean is it is it
even good enough to think about how much
encryption which has this property but
maybe for slightly more expressive
well functions are you can evaluate and
maybe is not that way
like right now you require that the
homework encryption scheme that has been
decryption
there's only linearly who morphic but
that puts other constraints on the
remaining components of the entire
construction yeah so maybe if you can
say okay decryption a.split decryption
and home or second caption system which
is slightly which has which can maybe
evaluate like linear additions plus
maybe one multiplication but then you
but less constraints on the other parts
of the entire this mixing schema is that
so you know the two assumptions which
know how to think these things are lwe
and DCR and there we both get this
additional property so it's unclear okay
yeah yeah so I guess if there are no
other questions yeah let's just thank
Sanjay for the wonderful talk and yeah
people can unmute themselves thanks
everybody for joining in today and next
week we will just have our last talk of
the the lattice seminar series and yeah
see you over then I'll stop the
recording sorry